Democrats open rhetorical fire on Liz
Warren at last night's presidential
primary debate which clashed with bado
O'Rourke's promised to confiscate or
rather mandatorily buy back every gun in
America but as Biden crumbles a couple
candidates try their hand at moderation
we will examine the winners and losers
then a new poll shows Democrats are
clamoring for a candidate who isn't even
running yet impeachment falls apart and
we celebrate international pronouns day
yes we do all that more I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
for the record on this international
pronouns day our preferred pronouns are
we us and our Matt Walsh taught us this
because we realized that when everyone
refers to us as us then nobody can ever
disagree with us because we are one and
that is our pronoun we have got to get
to this Democratic presidential debate
it was a surprisingly interesting one
not really on the surface on the surface
it was kind of the same petty sniping as
always but the central feature of this
debate was the crumbling of the Biden
campaign and a number of people leaping
to try to catch that moderate or more
moderate lane we will examine if anyone
can do it and if there's even such thing
as a moderate in the 2020 Democratic
primary but first I've got to thank our
friends over at ancestry
I love ancestry Benet a customer of
ancestry for long before the Daily wire
existed you can discover more about your
ancestors you can learn more about your
story by combining the ancestry DNA test
with billions of historical family
records so I did the test that's where
you've spit in the tube send it in and
they tell you so much about where your
family comes from but it's not just the
places where they come from ancestry
connects you to the places in the world
where your stories started using precise
Geographic detail and then clear-cut
historical insights and you can actually
trace your ancestors journeys over time
and you can follow how and why they
moved from place to place then you can
combine it with ancestor ease incredible
documents incredible amount of records
so you can really find out who's in your
family tree I love this my grandfather
spent years researching genealogy and
you get to find out so many cool things
about you I found out John and Simon
Knowles fought at the batterer Battle of
Bunker Hill and John died of his wounds
there and Simon went on and fought with
George Washington went to Valley Forge
with George Washington fought through
the whole Revolutionary War found all
that sort of stuff out of heaven in a
family tree on ancestry I found out I've
got four ancestors from the Mayflower
one of them a pilgrim the rest kind of a
little bit derelict one of them was John
Billington who was the first guy
executed for murder in the New World all
right not every record is going to be
flattering about your family but the
story will be incredibly interesting to
amplify your results you start a free
trial on ancestry you build a family
tree and your ancestors become more than
just a name you've got more than 100
million family trees billions of records
to give you more insight into your
genealogy and origins only ancestry can
tell such a rich story all the events
that shaped your family how they made a
living and it's so easy to get started I
love it you can you can love it as well
go to ancestry.com slash knowles kenda
wles do it today for 20% off your
ancestry DNA kit that is ancestry.com
slash Knowles came to wles for 20% off
your ancestry DNA kit this is great for
history buffs this is great for people
who just love their country it love
their family want to figure out more
about who they are ancestry.com slash
Knowles the Democratic Party is trying
to figure out who it is
during these presidential primary
debates the big clips the big highlights
that you see will go through some of
them it's all the sniping Amy Klobuchar
and Liz Warren and Kamla Harris gets
some shots in there at Liz Warren a lot
of people going after Liz Warren then
you got boo to judge and bado going
after each other and that's all very
interesting the central fact of the
debate is that Biden is falling apart
his polling is collapsing his ability to
stand on stage is collapsing Bernie
Sanders had a heart attack a week and a
half ago he seemed much much more lucid
and vibrant and energetic than Joe Biden
did and to our knowledge Joe Biden
hasn't had any heart attacks this was
all about Joe Biden he just he was
saying things that didn't make a lot of
sense he was kind of losing his train of
thought he was pushing different
analogies together it just didn't
inspire confidence that this is the guy
at one point Biden was explaining his
economic plans and he said he was gonna
he was gonna stop people from clipping
coupons in the stock market what I
talked about is how you get things done
and the way to get things done is take a
look at the tax code right now the idea
we have to start rewarding work not just
wealth I would eliminate
the capital gains tax that in our I
would raise the capital gains tax to the
highest rate of 39.5% I would double it
because guess what why in god's name
should someone who's clipping coupons in
the stock market make in fact pay a
lower tax rate than someone who in fact
is like I said the a school teacher and
a firefighter it's ridiculous and they
pay a lower tax so none of that is true
nothing he said even comes close to
approaching truth to be yeah I don't
even know how you judge the truth value
of the statement clipping coupons in the
stock market because people do not clip
coupons in this I guess they would be
really just really good frugal
stockbrokers if they clipped coot like
if there was some coupon to get a better
price on some some portion of a company
doesn't make any sense I think what he
was trying to say is people gambling in
the stock market that's that's a
frequent analogy you hear from the left
and that it's unfair that people who are
gambling are paying a lower tax rate
than their secretaries this is a line
warren buffett's used this line it just
isn't true it is not true at all
where does it come from it's because the
capital gains tax rate is lower than the
income tax rate for some people actually
it eat for people who you know if you're
talking about your secretary are you're
talking about the you know the janitor
is paying more a higher tax rate than
the the stockbroker or the hedge fund
manager that perhaps isn't isn't true
anyway even on the income tax rate but
what happens is for a lot of people who
work in finance they get a salary but
then they get most of their money as a
bonus or in when you're talking about
the millionaire billionaire class
they're paying capital gains on they're
paying capital gains taxes on their
investment income so you're not even
talking about bonuses you're not talking
about income you're just talking about
money that's in the market that's in
investments and then the money that you
make out of those investments you pay a
lower tax rate even on that that is
money that has already been taxed at the
corporate level so even that argument is
not true but what the way this gets
interpreted is that billion
as are paying less money in taxes than
their secretaries that is never true
that's not even close to true the
wealthy in this country paid virtually
all of the taxes the top 10% pay the
vast majority of taxes in this country
the top 1% pay lion's share of taxes in
this country I mean half of the country
doesn't pay any taxes at all in terms of
federal income taxes so this whole
argument is bogus
the problem with Biden is not that he's
making a bogus argument everybody was up
there it's that he wasn't even making
the argument well he was confusing his
words and then here's the knockout punch
they brought up Ukraine and resan Cooper
brings up Ukraine and Joe Biden
incredibly lies on camera again and says
he never discussed Ukraine with his son
said your son hunter today gave an
interview admitted that he made a
mistake and showed poor judgment by
serving on the board in Ukraine did you
make a mistake by letting him you were
the point person on Ukraine at the time
if you can answer look my son's
statement speaks for itself I did my job
I never discussed a single thing with my
son about anything having to do with her
crane
no one has indicated I have we've always
kept everything separate even when my
son was the Attorney General of the
state of Delaware we never discussed it
so there'd be no potential conflict okay
there's a lot of confusion here first of
all he says he's doubling down in a
statement that he made that no one has
ever suggested that Joe Biden talked
with Ukraine or talked with his son
about Ukraine and there's no evidence of
that at all the trouble is someone has
suggested that the person who suggested
that was hunter Biden in a New Yorker
profile in July and he actually
reiterated that statement on Good
Morning America on ABC News two days ago
did you and your father ever discuss
Ukraine no as I said the only time was
after a news account it wasn't a
discussion in any way there's no buts to
this no we never did what hold on hold
on you say did you ever discuss Ukraine
he goes no just one time there was one
time we did oh shoot they told me not to
say that ah yeah no there's no but we
didn't wasn't even a discussion sure we
I said something he said something we
were talking
about it but that's not I wouldn't call
that a discussion it was more of a
discourse it was more of a colloquy it
was a next question plays past next
question Joe Biden even in his answer by
the way he says we never talked about
Ukraine even when my son was the
Attorney General of Delaware that's not
the son we're talking about Joe his son
Beau Biden his late son Beau Biden was
the Attorney General of Delaware the son
who was on the Ukrainian Energy Board
was hunter Biden 100 Button says he did
talk about it and hunter Biden goes on
because Good Morning America to their
credit actually pushed him on it they
said hold on you're saying you didn't
talk about it then you're saying you did
talk about it by the way what were you
doing on the board in the first place
your dad said I hope you know what
you're doing hope you know what's he
doing I do and I said I do and that was
literally the end of our discussion why
because my dad was vice president the
United States there's literally nothing
as a young man or as a full-grown adult
that my father in some way hasn't had
influence over as it does not serve
either one of us when he said I hope you
know what you're doing what did he think
you were doing well he read the press
reports that I joined the board of
Purisima which was a Ukrainian natural
gas company and there's been a lot of
misinformation about me not about my dad
nobody buys that but it buys this idea
that I was unqualified to be on the
board well were your qualifications to
be on the board of Murray's Matt well I
was vice chairman of the board of Amtrak
for five years I was the chairman of the
board of the UN World Food Program I was
a lawyer for Boise Schiller Flexner one
of the most prestigious law firms in the
world you didn't have any extensive
knowledge about natural gas or Ukraine
itself though no but I think that I had
as much knowledge as anybody else that
was on the board I think not more yeah
this is this is not going well for
hunter Biden because he's right he
probably didn't have any less knowledge
than anyone else on the board this is a
crooked board that's what generally
that's what boards are certainly an
oligarchic country is like Ukraine when
in corrupt countries like Ukraine they
say what previous experience did you
have what qualified you to be on the
board of this Ukrainian energy company
while you're while your father was vice
president he was well I was on the board
of Amtrak you know that other company
that has a relationship to the federal
government that my father famously
travels on so much that they call him
Amtrak Joe yeah I was on that so what
are you calling me
nepotistic work for ya and before that I
was on another board and hey look there
what I did have one real job I worked
for Boise Schiller which is maybe the
most famous Democratic lobbying law firm
in the country okay all right doesn't
acquit himself very well here so Biden
collapses on stage in real time two ways
to respond to this for the Democratic
Party and for the candidates they can
either remain hard-line progressives or
they can try to take Bernie or Biden's
place in the moderate lane because that
moderate Lane now is falling apart so
there is an opening here I was wondering
I thought why on earth was the LGBTQ
Town Hall on Friday what was the purpose
of this and then it occurred to me
people were tweeting about this they had
that LGBTQ crazytown town hall on Friday
because then it allowed the Democrats to
look more moderate at this debate just a
week later less than a week later while
and not having to discuss any of the
LGBTQ issues in the pronouns and the
genders so there was a real opening and
I think the Democratic Party tried to
try to make sure it looked this way an
opening for a moderate now some
candidates can't take that Bernie
Sanders is never going to be a moderate
he went full bore leftist last night he
said on the leftist issue par excellence
climate change you said it's the
greatest threat that the planet has ever
faced this planet faces the greatest
threat in its history from climate
change and the green New Deal that I
have advocated will create up to 20
million jobs as we move away from fossil
fuel to energy efficiency and
sustainable energy
all right the weather which may or may
not increase and temperatures slightly a
little bit over the next century is the
greatest threat the planet has ever
faced
says Bernie Sanders the man who probably
never heard of the cretaceous-paleogene
mass extinction event three quarters of
life on Earth wiped out it probably
doesn't hurt of that one so he's just
it's a little historical ignorance for
him that's the far left that's about as
far left as you go with Bernie Sanders
beta or orc also trying to play into
that left lane Beto's campaign is
falling apart I mean there was pretty
much no reason he should be at this
debate anymore and so he's be
been trying to signal that he's as left
as they come over the past few months
this is after a career where he played
himself off mostly as a moderate in
Congress and so he obviously doesn't
believe in anything but he felt left ism
was gonna bring him all the way it looks
like that's not gonna work so he's one
last try is going to say that we're
gonna undermine the Second Amendment
he's gonna take away all your guns gonna
go door to door take them all away how
exactly are you gonna force people to
give up their weapons you don't even
know who has those weapons look we're
gonna make sure that the priority is
saving the lives of our fellow Americans
I think almost everyone on this stage
agrees that it's not right and as
president would seek to ban the sale of
ar-15s and ak-47s those are weapons of
war they were designed to kill people
effectively efficiently on a battlefield
to be clear exactly how are you going to
take away weapons from people who do not
want to give them up and you don't know
where they are if someone does not turn
in an ar-15 or an ak-47 one of these
weapons of war or brings out in public
and embraces it in an attempt to
intimidate as we saw when we were at
Kent State recently then that weapon
will be taken from them if they persist
there will be other consequences from
law enforcement other consequences so
we're going for it I'm bait oh hell yeah
we're gonna take your ar-15 we're going
door-to-door we're gonna get the cops to
come and steal all your guns and
completely undermine the Constitution
one thing that really bothers me this
was probably the highlight of the night
in terms of Orwellian language every
aspect of this gun debate is dishonest
so there's no such thing as a mandatory
buyback the government didn't sell you
your gun in the first place so it's not
going to buy it back from you I guess
you could try to buy guns from people if
you're the government but if it's a
mandatory buyback then you ain't buying
it
it's not like it's a free exchange where
money is changing hands it's the
government confiscating your weapons
mandatory buyback well absolutely
outrageous same thing with weapons of
war all weapons or weapons of war all of
military are all of firearm technology
advances because of war because of armed
conflict that is the impetus for
improving firearm technology that's been
true since the
of time and will remain true in the
future and then the other one is assault
weapon all weapons are assault weapons
all weapons are assault weapons they
were designed to assault you if a weapon
is not designed to assault you it's not
a weapon like this left is tears tumbler
is not a weapon because it's not meant
to assault you it's meant to receive the
leftist tears after you have been
assaulted by facts and logic so that
language just goes on and on throughout
the entire debate bado is running on it
it's not going anywhere he probably
won't even be at the next debate Pete
Buddha judge however sees Bernie's going
far of hard left
Beto's going hard left Liz Warren
doesn't know exactly where she wants to
be so Buddha judge season-opening
because of the early part of this
primary he was doing pretty well he was
getting some press because he was the
reasonable one he was at least
pretending to be a Christian he was at
least pretending to be moderate he was
at least pretending to be a good old boy
from the Midwest and so Buddha judge
takes on bado o'rourke head-on and
pretty much wipes the floor with him on
the question of guns
let's follow their inspiration and lead
and not be limited by the polls and the
consultants and the focus groups to do
what's right there Buddha just promised
in the polls the problem is the policy
and I don't need lessons from you on
courage political or personal everyone
on this stage is determined to get
something done everyone on this stage
recognizes a release I thought we did
that the problem is not other Democrats
who don't agree with your particular
idea of how to handle this the problem
is the National Rifle Association and
their enablers in Congress and we should
be united in taking the fight for that
poor bado you can see it in his eyes he
just thinks oh man I totally walked into
that meas he's saying we need the
courage to steal people's guns and
undermine the Constitution and there's
Pete Buddha jej who comes in at these
one of two people on that stage who's
ever served in the military so I don't
need a lessons from you about courage
totally wipes the floor with him so
Buddha judge trying to take that
moderate Lane the other person on stage
was gunning for that moderate Lane was
Amy Klobuchar and Amy Klobuchar showed
up to this debate with one goal in mind
that was to destroy Elizabeth Warren
Warren delenda est Warren must be
destroyed she even showed up wearing the
exact same outfit that Liz Warren was
wearing which was a little coincidental
and slightly creepy and she just kept up
her attacks on Warren all night long I
want to give a reality check here to
Elizabeth because no one on this stage
wants to protect billionaires not even
the billionaire wants to protect
billionaire approaches your idea is not
the only idea I appreciate Elizabeth's
work but again the difference between a
plan and a pipe dream is something that
you can actually get done and we can get
this public option done and we can take
on the pharmaceutical companies and
bring down the prices get her drag her
Amy yes Queen I don't I don't know all
this late lingo but that's that's
basically what I was feeling when I saw
this happen especially because amy
klobuchar is about his lame a candidate
as you can possibly get she tries to
make these same jokes over and over she
doesn't know how to deliver them she's
got this voice that doesn't sound really
inspiring and she speaks in a really
kind of realistic way at least relative
to the Democratic Party so she's almost
certainly out going anywhere but she did
have a relatively good debate and she's
she's hitting Warren on the unreality of
her proposal she's hitting Warren on
Warren not being honest about how she's
gonna pay for everything at the same
time that Warren's getting hit from the
left on not being honest about how she's
gonna pay for everything so it's good
time she's vulnerable and Columbia chars
is trying to take that Layne Warren
herself for that matter he was trying to
seem more moderate in last night's
debate she doesn't think that her her
vulnerability is on the left that she
needs to move more to the left she's
seeing it more on the moderate side and
so she gets into an exchange with Kamala
Harris
Kamala who's running far to the left
Kamala who's a total joke and she's
saying that we need to kick Trump off
Twitter it's a matter of national
importance that Twitter a company kicks
the president of the United States off
of its platform and are you senator
Warren gonna go for that Liz Warren
backs off it and Kamala just tries to
nail her on it because here we have
Donald Trump
well it's 60
five million Twitter followers and is
using that platform as the President of
the United States to openly intimidate
witnesses to threaten witnesses to
obstruct justice and he and his account
should be taken down okay so she's you
got to do this you got to go after her
okay it was a good hit
it made Kamala looked like the tougher
more leftist one Liz Warren didn't
didn't want to respond to this
the trouble with Kamala though is when
she thinks she did something sort of
well she just hammers it ad nauseam
until it seems disingenuous and she
loses any credit that you would have
gotten for the hit in the first place
she goes on don't look I don't just want
to push Donald Trump off Twitter I want
to push him out of the White House
that's our job but the way join me in
saying that let's figure out know why it
is that we have had laws on the books
for antitrust so she is pushing for that
Liz Warren is moderating and then
Camilla really really just shows herself
to be the weak candidate that she is on
paper Camilla Harris could have been a
killer candidate she could have been a
real top-tier contender but she's just
not good at presenting herself with any
kind of sincerity to the American people
everything feels contrived everything
feels like she's trying to be a little
too cool and her her conclusion her big
her big inspirational statement of this
debate was with regard to president
Trump dude got to go this is a crisis of
Donald Trump's making and it is on a
long list of crises of Donald Trump's
making and that's why do gotta go and
when I am commander-in-chief we will
stop this madness dude gotta go you have
nothing to fear but fear itself we will
go to the moon not because it is easy
but because it is hard mr. Gorbachev
tear down this wall dude gotta go there
one of these things is not like the
other in the
history of presidential rhetoric and
that would be common low Harris's
attempts so she's not a serious
candidate she needs to go home and work
on her skills for four or eight years
and maybe maybe she can try again she's
got a good resume but she's really bad
on stage then you had you had to ask
yourself this question they're trying to
moderate Amy Klobuchar Pete Budaj edge
even Elizabeth Warren they're trying to
moderate are they moderate and you
realize no the parties are actually too
far apart now the conservative movement
and the Republican Party is now much
more conservative the Democratic Party
is much more leftist so we're thrilled
when a candidate says maybe maybe one of
the biggest tech platforms shouldn't
censor the President of the United
States we're thrilled we're like oh
thank you so much how great were
thrilled when a candidate says maybe we
shouldn't steal all of Americans guns we
think oh you're so moderate Tulsi
Gabbard has been getting a lot of credit
for being the moderate in the race she's
not she's not she came out last night
and supported the universal basic income
which is a massive massive expansion of
the welfare system like you've never
seen before in America and that would
get every single American hooked on the
teat of government she endorses it just
flippantly last night I agree with my
friend Andrew yang I think universal
basic income is a good idea to help
provide that security so that people can
have the freedom to make the kinds of
choices that they want to see that's the
moderate welfare for all that's the big
moderate and then it's not just on
economic issues Tulsi Gabbard is getting
a lot of credit because she she's a
moderate on abortion according to
today's Democratic Party but today a
moderate on abortion is just Hillary
Clinton in 2008 it's it's even a little
more radical than that Tulsi Gabbard is
saying that maybe we shouldn't kill
babies after 26 weeks after they're so
obviously babies and after they can
obviously survive outside of the womb
but before that fair game
you can kill whoever you want this is
often one of the most difficult
decisions that a woman will ever have to
make and it's unfortunate to see how in
this country it has first
so long been used as a divisive
political weapon I agree with Hillary
Clinton on one thing disagree with her
on many others but when she said
abortion should be safe legal and rare I
think she's correct we see how the
consequences of laws that you're
referring to can often lead to a
dangerous place as we've seen them as
their past in other countries where a
woman who has a miscarriage passed that
6 weeks could be imprisoned because
abortion would be illegal at that point
I do however think that there should be
some restrictions in place
I support codifying roe v wade while
making sure that during the third
trimester abortion is not an option
unless the life or severe health
consequences of a woman are at risk okay
so hey look that's something all the
other candidates support abortion
basically up until the minute you're
born then the law in New York signed by
Andy Cuomo is that you can kill a baby
as it's being born and that's perfectly
legal and in Virginia the governor of
Virginia said you can kill a baby after
he's been born so I guessed LC is
relatively moderate on this but that's
not moderation it's also I love this
this argument that this is what they
would say abortion is one of the most
difficult decisions a woman will ever
have to make first of all the vast
majority of women don't get abortions
but plenty of women do get abortions I
know people who have gotten abortions
good friends of mine have gotten
abortions most of them to my knowledge
deeply regret it now that's another
story for another time but it's not a
decision that a woman has to make you
don't have to kill your baby it's like
saying not killing your mother-in-law is
one of the most difficult decisions you
ever have to make it would be maybe
convenient maybe you have somewhere an
impetus to do it but it's always wrong
it is always wrong and it is just as
ridiculous to talk about the the
difficult decision and the right to
choose to kill your mother-in-law as it
is to talk about the difficult decision
in the right to kill your own child it's
actually I think it's pretty less
ridiculous to talk about the
mother-in-law thing that is a ridiculous
and silly argument if you can't kill the
baby at 26 weeks if it's wrong to kill
the baby at 26
long after it can live outside the womb
by the way because technology is
advantage so much
you've got babies living outside the
woman 20 weeks now so you're talking six
weeks after that that's a lot but if
it's wrong to kill the baby at 26 weeks
why is it right to kill the baby at 25
weeks well Michael it's so blurry it's
just it's a great mystery of when life
begins no there's no mystery we know
when life begins the little thing in
there is moving around it's got a
heartbeat at 10 or 15 days well it's
just but when you know it's just so
complicated it's not complicated
it's the same little baby at 26 weeks as
it is at 25 weeks
how about 24 weeks 23 22 21 you know one
of the most insane lines of the night
Cory Booker I don't even want to give
Cory Booker air time Cory Booker said
that the right to an abortion the right
to kill babies is one of the most
sacrosanct ideals in the country those
are his exact words he said the right to
kill a baby is a fundamental ideal is
sacrosanct sacred to kill a baby and I
thought is there any way you could make
that argument something we're a
sacrosanct I deal in this country
obviously it's never sacred to kill a
baby only in really awful terrible pagan
religions but where do we get our
sacrosanct ideals well often we look to
the Declaration of Independence which
says that we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men are created
equal that they are endowed by their
creator with certain unalienable rights
including life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness doesn't say that men get
those rights at 26 weeks or 27 weeks or
25 weeks says they are created with
those rights when are you created you're
not created at 26 weeks at 26 weeks
you're the same entity the same being
that you were at 25 weeks 24 23 22 you
are created at your conception that's
what the words mean not that they've
read the Declaration of Independence
anytime recently we got a lot more to
get to we've got to get
a secret candidate in the race who's
polling better than anybody right now in
the entire Democratic primary then we've
got to get to impeachment and then of
course we have to get to international
pronouns day but you got to go to daily
wire.com to do that ten bucks a month
hundred hours for an annual membership
you get me get the andrew Clavin show
you get the Ben Shapiro show you get the
Matt Walsh show you get to ask questions
in the mail bag you get another Kingdom
which is now the third episode is out
just was released this Monday
subscribers get it on Friday it's really
good getting a lot of good reviews and
thank you for the notes for those of you
have sent in nice notes about it you get
everything can you get the leftist
here's tumblr go to daily wire comm
we'll be right back with a lot more
who won the debate there's no real
winner I would say Liz Warren did very
well she is still leading in the field
of the people who really helped
themselves during the debate p2g and Amy
Club you charge it did a lot of good for
themselves I think Amy Klobuchar is
still so unlikable she's still so
distant from the electorate and the
audience that she doesn't really have a
chance
Pete muda judge is excellent on the
campaign trail and really understands
how to connect to people and I think
he's the biggest jerk in the whole race
and a scold and the heretic and an
absolute jerk but credit where credit's
due he's a pretty good candidate so he
helped himself a lot nevertheless these
candidates and and Bernie helped himself
by looking very energetic which he did
none of these candidates or the
clear-cut winners none of these
clannad's candidates are obviously the
person who's going to get the nomination
and the reason I know this is because of
a recent poll came out from Boston
Herald and Franklin Pierce University
survey this was released on Monday it
showed a three-way tie for the top spot
in New Hampshire more or less a
three-way tie Elizabeth Warren at 25
percent support former Vice President
Joe Biden at 24 percent Bernie Sanders
at 22 percent so mostly a tie the Liz
Warren is at the top of that there was a
candidate however who came in at 26
percent the reason that candidate didn't
register right away is because the
candidate is not running for president
that candidate is drumroll Michelle
Obama Michelle Obama if she jumped into
the race according to this one poll in
New Hampshire she would get 26 percent
of support from likely Democratic
primary voters in New Hampshire and
Warren and Biden would be a 20 percent
in Sanders would be a 15 percent if
Michelle Obama got into the race this
has long been floated as a possibility
Michelle Obama is very well-liked
she's comes from an era that Democrats
more or less enjoy and or nostalgic for
she's she checks intersectional boxes
which is
apparently important to the Democratic
primary voters in 2020 now if she
actually did jump into the race those
numbers would drop very quickly because
all candidates are better hypothetically
than they are in reality it's like that
Paul Simon song Kodachrome everything
looks worse in black and white so is the
line and when I think back on all the
girls I knew in high school if I put
them all together for one night I know
they'd never match my sweet imagination
everything looks worse in black and
white and so if you get the candidates
who are now in this vivid color in your
imagination when you put them on the
campaign trail everything is black and
white everything's very stark
everything's very clear and so Michelle
Obama's numbers would drop but what it
suggests that voters at least in New
Hampshire are yearning for her is that
there is a sense they're starting to
come to their senses that you need a
more moderate candidate you don't really
want candidates who think there are 750
genders and who Leon Castro who thinks
that we should have abortion rights for
men and bado or or Chris's we're gonna
take away all of your guns definitely
not New Hampshire you don't really want
that it's like every but people do this
in meetings people do this in group
settings sometimes they just go with the
madness of the crowd so if everyone's
talking in a particular way you just
want to fit in I mean you want to be a
part of them so you kind of go along
even though you don't really believe it
maybe the guy was telling you doesn't
really believe it maybe nobody really
believes it I think you're starting to
see that with the left ISM of the
Democratic Party you're seeing very
slowly it takes them a long time but
very slowly coming to the realization
that this is not gonna play in Peoria
and we wouldn't really want it to even
if we could that creates a yearning for
somebody like Michelle Obama but it's
it's a it's a yearning that it's looking
for a real candidate it's not really
looking for Michelle Obama it's looking
for a real candidate to come in and fill
that Lane so far no one has a lot of
people are comparing this election in
2020 to the Republicans in 2016 on the
surface there are a lot of similarities
you know there's so many candidates in
2016 there were 17
Republicans now that were down to 12
Democrats but there are so many more who
were running and the idea being that in
2016 the Republicans thought they could
beat Hillary Clinton and in 2020 the
Democrats think they can beat Trump and
so everybody is running but I don't
think that comparison holds it all in
2016 you had really good Republican
candidates almost all of the candidates
were really top tier candidates Trump
kind of came out of nowhere for most
political observers but Ted Cruz
top-tier candidate Marco Rubio and any
other election would have been a serious
contender even John Kasich was a very
successful governor kind of annoying
personality on the campaign trail but
successful Governor Chris Christie one
of the most popular governors in the
country the list goes on and on who do
we have in 2020 for the Democrats it's
kind of a bunch of nobodies who Leon
Castro is like truly a no but former
Secretary of HUD and a mayor of San
Antonio Pete Budaj edge the mayor of
South Bend Indiana population 100,000
Amy Klobuchar Tim O'Brien remember Tim
O'Brien me neither
Eric's wall well those those are not
comparable fields I actually think the
greater similarity for the Democrats in
2020 isn't not the Republicans in 2016
it's Republicans in 2012 2012 you have a
lot of Republicans running Mitt Romney
eventually got the nomination that went
great didn't it you had all the serious
candidates stay off the table because
they didn't think it was going to be
possible to unseat Barack Obama the
incumbent has a great advantage and so
it was mostly a clown show for 2012 I
think that's sort of what you're seeing
in 2020 and if certain Democrats want to
get in the race a Michelle Obama for
instance or somebody like her I think
they're gonna wait until they have a
clearer shot in 2024 and and some of my
evidence for this is there the Democrats
again like the madness of crowds are
trying to convince themselves that Trump
is going to be impeached or removed from
office this impeachment thing is falling
apart right now Nancy Pelosi just gave a
press conference in which she completely
forgot the reason that she's ostensibly
trying to impeach Trump our founders had
very deep suspicions about foreigners
interfering and our
government and as again in our elections
and the emoluments clauses they're put
there specifically for that purpose to
protect us from any influence of foreign
governments so the fact that we would be
here in an inquiry that relates to the
president asking a foreign government to
help the president in his re-election by
withhold granting or withholding the
timing of military assistance that had
been voted on by the Congress
it's just has so many violations in it
it undermines our national security we
were sending of that military assistance
because of Ukraine needing that visa
beat Russia all roads seem to lead to
Putin with the president though isn't it
so all roads seem to lead to Putin no no
Nancy Nancy that was the last time you
were trying to impeach Trump last time
you tried to impeach Trump you said he
was colluding with the Russians and
Vladimir Putin this time you're saying
he's colluding with the Ukrainians who
were Russia's sworn enemy and how did
that happen I don't know you haven't
really explained that but you got to
keep your impeachment stories straight
especially when the two stories
contradict one another yeah Trump is
cozying up to Russia where is it Ukraine
or is it's one of those - yeah he's
cozying up to the US or is it the USSR I
forgot one of those to have anyway he's
a bad guy we're gonna beat him that's
what there was extremely Daniels he
cozied up to stormy Daniels quite
literally I guess in that case it's it's
falling apart I mean even she can't keep
the story straight now they're saying
that they might not take a vote on
impeachment anytime soon and this is why
I haven't taken the impeachment inquiry
very seriously they are not following
any sort of constitutional process right
now in the house if you want to impeach
a president you got to vote for it you
got a book you got to go on the record
this is why Nancy Pelosi isn't saying
they're impeaching the president what
she's saying is we're launching a formal
official impeachment inquiry to begin to
inquire as to whether or not we should
ask people to lunch to talk about taking
a boat
whether to impeach the president that's
not that's not real that's not a real
thing they want to get the credit for
impeachment without actually having to
go through the difficult political
rigmarole there are polls out there's a
Gallup poll out that shows the majority
of people now support impeachment and
removing Trump from office there was the
Fox News poll said majority people
support impeachment so why aren't the
Democrats moving full steam ahead I
think the reason is they know they know
how this is gonna play out public
opinion moves back and forth very
quickly especially on highly politicized
questions like impeachment especially in
the heat of an election campaign and
they just know that it's going to put
them in a politically vulnerable
position because they don't have
anything maybe they'll find something
I'm not saying that Trump is totally
squeaky-clean on everything I'm sure
he's got there's a lot of things they
could get him on in his taxes or in this
or that you know you could indict a ham
sandwich but does any of that rise to
the level of high crimes and
misdemeanors does any of that become an
impeachable offense and are they going
to be able to say to a strip with a
straight face to the American people yes
we're going to impeach the president and
overturn the 2016 election in the one
year or less before another presidential
election because the president had a
phone call with Ukraine that you've
already read that is fine no probably
not
so that's falling apart and this gets to
not just a political question but a
cultural question which is the the
internal logic of our politics is
falling apart because more broadly we
have difficulty speaking to one another
we have difficulty understanding our own
history around constitutional processes
we're just not as smart as we used to be
in our self-government and in our
republic this seems to happen to
republics republics and democracies
become decadent they become a little
soft intellectually and spiritually and
institutionally and that seems to be
happening you see it probably most
clearly today because today is a holiday
today is international pronouns day you
know you know every day on Twitter seems
to be a different kind of day it's like
cheeseburger day or sibling day well
this month is the second month of the
year dedicated to the LGBTQ
sexual revolution movement and so we've
now got a sixth of the year dedicated to
four-and-a-half percent of the
population
half of whom I suspect don't buy into
any of this ridiculous nonsense it's
international pronouns day and maybe a
lot of people aren't acknowledging it
but who Leon Castro Democratic candidate
for president sure is he put a tweet out
he said using someone's correct pronouns
and giving your own isn't difficult I'm
who Leon Castro he him l should be hit
he him his but he made it L because he
can't keep his languages straight
because he's not so good at at thinking
he's not so good with the stuff between
the ears he goes on it takes one extra
breath to help people feel seen and
respected I think that's worth it
hashtag pronouns day what he said here
obviously everything is total nonsense
but what he said at the very top is
explicitly incorrect he said using
someone's correct pronouns meaning if
you call a man who identifies as a woman
she according to WHO leon castro that's
correct but of course it's not correct
he is it remains that he even if he puts
on a dress so his correct pronoun would
be he to misgender him would be to use
the new politically correct transgender
pronouns this is an argument over what
truth is itself is truth objective
reality or is truth your subjective
feelings that change every single day
that is now a debate this debate would
have been unthinkable unthinkable a year
ago or two years ago now it is a debate
that is being had at the presidential
level international pronouns day
somebody put this together has a website
they say it seeks to make respecting
sharing and educating about personal
pronouns commonplace fair enough they go
on the international pronouns day
website is actually much more honest
about this they don't use really loaded
terms like correct pronouns to refer to
incorrect pronouns but they explain the
logic referring to people by the
pronouns they determine for themselves
is basic to human dignity being referred
to by the wrong pronouns right there we
go now you get that language the wrong
pronouns as you feel it particularly
effects transgender and gender
non-conforming people together we can
transform society to celebrate people's
multiple intersecting identities this is
more or less an honest take and it shows
you the stakes of this they're saying
that referring to people by the pronouns
they determine for themselves is basic
to human dignity that is not true that's
the opposite of true they're saying
indulging people's fantasies and lying
to people is basic to human dignity no
that's an affront to human dignity what
is basic to human dignity is treating
people with respect and treating people
with respect means not lying to them and
not treating them like children and not
condescending and not patronizing but
treating them as you would like to be
treated which is to be told the truth
together we can transform society that's
what they want to do they want to
transform society this is not just some
coups on Twitter this is not just some
random website this is debate being had
at the presidential level that is the
stake those are the stakes rather the
transformation of society not just
raising taxes or lowering taxes not even
just banning one gun and another gun not
even just saying we're gonna protect
human life at this week and not at that
week this transformation will get down
to the nature of reality itself and who
has the right to define it and who has
the right to pervert it and who has the
right to declare that any sort of truth
exists at all that's the stakes we'll
see how that plays out in the next seven
Democratic presidential primary debates
and then of course in 2020 that's our
show on Michael Noel's this is the
Michael Nolt show see you tomorrow
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boy
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel why
douse key edited by danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by mike core amina hair and
makeup is by Jessa alvera and our
production assistant is Nick Sheehan the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune into the
Ben Shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there